Speaker 1: Because after all, it's only January
of 2023. We are not paying much attention to 2024
polling. We're looking at it sort of every three
weeks, every four weeks. I can't quite remember
the last time we looked at it, but it is not
irrelevant, and particularly when we are asking
the question, is Trump's campaign for the primary
nomination imploding before it even gets going
when we are not yet sure that Joe Biden is running
for reelection because, despite what he says,
he has not actually announced that he is running
for reelection at this time or filed to run for
reelection, there's a lot of question marks and
interesting things going on in the aftermath of
the 2022 midterms, etc.. So let's look at where
the numbers are. And this morning, there was a
headline, Trump leads Biden in hypothetical
2024 matchup, according to a new poll. That
is indeed true. Emerson College has released a
new poll which finds that Trump is leading Biden
44 to 41. However, you do have 14% of respondents
who are not in either camp yet. 10% say, Well,
I would support someone else. 4% were simply
undecided. But I think the takeaway, given
that Emerson is a pretty good pollster and we'll
see how good in a moment is that it is very much
not a foregone conclusion that Trump can't win or
that Trump is certain to win. And it is very much
not a foregone conclusion that Joe Biden would
have an easy time getting reelected or that Joe
Biden would be unable to get himself reelected.
Neither. It is a very, very unclear scenario. Now,
if we want to zoom out a little bit and say,
okay, but David, that's one poll from Emerson.
What if we look a little more broadly? I love that
idea. So then we would go to Fivethirtyeight's
aggregation of different polls and there you
will find the Emerson poll. I just mentioned
the Emerson poll, that's an A-minus rated pollster
in a Biden DeSantis matchup. It's essentially even
it's Biden plus one. And in that Biden Trump
matchup, as I just told you, Emerson has it,
Trump plus three. But what about other pollsters?
Well, let's look Morning Consult, which is a B
rated pollster, has a poll that one day newer in
Biden versus DeSantis. They have DeSantis ahead,
whereas in Biden versus Trump, they have Biden
ahead by three points. All right. What about a
different poll? Well, we have one from a few days
ago. This is a Harris poll. Harris is a B-plus
rated pollster. In that poll, Biden DeSantis has
de Santos up three and Biden. Trump has Trump up
five. And then lastly, and this is the last one,
because then we'll get to our bigger observations,
YouGov, which is a B-plus rated
pollster Biden. Trump has Biden up four,
and in a slightly different formulation,
they have Biden up six. That's
registered voters versus what is a I
forget what A is not actual likely anyway.
And then in Biden DeSantis, they have it even. So
what's the real takeaway here? The real takeaway
is not know. One of these polls is really
going to tell us everything that we need to
know. The takeaway is anything quite literally
could happen in 2024. We are not even really
in the primary season. Donald Trump did something
that sort of out of not out of character for him,
but it's out of norms historically to announce so
early that he is running. He is scheduled to start
campaign events soon, although I don't know that
they're going to be massive rallies. In fact,
he does have an event in South Carolina this
weekend. Our correspondent Luke Beasley will be
there and we will have clips of interviews with
South Carolinian Trump supporters for you on an
upcoming program. The takeaway is we don't have
any idea what could happen. And so any statements
that sound like foregone conclusions of the sort
of Biden doesn't have to worry or Biden has no
chance. Trump's got this in the bag or Trump
has no chance. None of those statements are
accurate at this point in time. Now, what about
the Republican primary? This is a very interesting
question because there is a candidate who has not
even announced that he is running, Ron DeSantis,
who had some polling that looked pretty good more
recently. It doesn't look quite so good for Ron
DeSantis. In a recent Morning Consult poll, Trump
is leading DeSantis by 19 in the primary. In a
recent Emerson poll, Trump is leading to Santos
by 26. In a recent berated Big Village poll,
Trump is leading DeSantis by 23. And in a
recent Harris poll, Trump is leading to Santos.
But Trump, Tim Scott, Trump plus 50. Oh, this
is oh, this is against other people. Okay. Trump
is leading DeSantis by ten in a Harris poll.
So even though there was a period about a. A
month ago or so where Ron DeSantis was actually
leading Trump in a bunch of different polls,
despite the fact that Trump has announced and
DeSantis has not, which was quite stunning, it
does not seem to be the most common scenario right
now. That's where we are. Anything could happen.
Anything could change. But we will follow it
probably like roughly every three or four weeks.